>> YOU KNOW WHY WE HAVE CASES SO
MUCH?
ALL WE DO IS TEST.
IF WE CUT OUR TESTING DONE IN
HALF, THEY’D SAY -- WELL, THEY
WOULDN’T SAY THAT.
BUT CASES WOULD GO DOWN.
NOW WE HAVE THE BEST TESTS, AND
WE ARE COMING AROUND.
WE ARE BOUNDING THE TURN.
WE HAVE THE VACCINES, WE HAVE
EVERYTHING.
WE ARE BOUNDING THE TURN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
EVEN WITHOUT THE VACCINES, WE
ARE BOUNDING THE TURN.
IT’S GOING TO BE OVER.
>> Harris: PRESIDENT TRUMP,
AGAIN, SAYING WE ARE ROUNDING
THE CORNER ON CORONAVIRUS
DESPITE CONCERNS AS CASES ARISE,
AND, MOST IMPORTANT BECOME A
HOSPITALIZATIONS IN SEVERAL
STATES.
MORE THAN 83,000 NEW INFECTIONS
NATIONWIDE ON FRIDAY.
A RECORD ONE-DAY INCREASE SINCE
WHAT WE SAW AT 77,000 IN JULY.
WE ARE MOVING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION, THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TELL US.
TRUMP ALLY AND FORMER NEW JERSEY
GOVERNOR, CHRIS CHRISTIE,
APPEARS TO CRITICIZE
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE’S DECISION
TO KEEP HIS CAMPAIGN ON SCHEDULE
AFTER FIVE PEOPLE CLOSE TO
MR. PENCE TESTED POSITIVE FOR
THE VIRUS.
>> THE WHOLE GETTING OF COVID,
TO BEGIN WITH, AND NOT WEARING A
MASK HAS BEEN A PROBLEM.
I’VE TALKED ABOUT THAT OVER THE
LAST COUPLE WEEKS.
I THINK EVERYBODY HAS GOT TO PUT
THE HEALTH OF THE PEOPLE THEY
ARE GOING TO BE IN TOUCH WITH
FIRST.
YOU’VE GOT TO KEEP YOURSELF AWAY
FROM EVERYBODY.
I AM A LITTLE BIT SURPRISED.
>> Harris: I WANT TO BRING IN
NO WHITE HOUSE DEPUTY
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR, BRIAN
MORGENSTERN.
BRIAN, THANK YOU FOR BEING ON
THE PROGRAM TODAY.
MY FIRST QUESTION FOR YOU, WITH
ALL THESE HEADLINES ABOUT THE
NOVEL CORONAVIRUS, WHAT IS THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE PRESIDENT’S
LATEST STRATEGY FOR THIS
PRECIPITOUS SPIKE?
WHICH, AGAIN, WE ARE TESTING.
THEY ARE RUNNING OUT OF ICU
BEDS.
>> HARRIS, I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION FOR THE PRESIDENT’S
RESPONSE HAS BEEN HISTORIC.
A BIG PART OF THAT HAS BEEN THE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE
CONSTANTLY COMMUNICATING WITH
STATE AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS,
ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE
EVERYTHING THEY NEED ON A
PROACTIVE BASIS.
WE HAVE HAD FEMA, WE’VE HAD THE
ADMIRAL MAKING SURE THAT EVERY
JURISDICTION HAS SUPPLIES, THAT
THEY HAVE PERSONNEL, THAT THEY
HAVE MEDICATION, THAT THEY HAVE
EVERYTHING THEY NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE RISK OF THIS VIRUS
IS MUCH LOWER THAN IT EVER HAS
BEEN, AND THAT’S THE CASE.
BECAUSE WITH
OPERATION WARP SPEED WE HAVE
TREATMENTS COMING TO MARKET
FASTER THAN EVER, SOON WE’LL
HAVE VACCINES COMING TO MARKET.
MAYBE FIVE TIMES FASTER THAN
EVER.
PEOPLE ARE NOT DYING OF THIS
DISEASE NEARLY AT THE RATE THEY
WEAR.
WE KNOW HOW TO ISOLATE THE
VULNERABLE.
WE KNOW HOW TO TREAT PEOPLE,
OFTEN TIMES ON AN OUTPATIENT
BASIS.
SO THE RISKS JUST AREN’T WHAT
THEY USED TO BE.
WE KNOW HOW TO SAFELY REOPEN, WE
KNOW HOW TO MITIGATE, AND WE
KNOW HOW TO TREAT PEOPLE.
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY ARE
IT.
THANKS TO PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE
TASK FORCE, AND
OPERATION WARP SPEED.
>> Harris: I WANT TO FOLLOW
UP.
THIS IS ONLY BASED ON THE
SCIENCE.
CORONAVIRUS IS THE SAME TYPE OF
VIRUS THAT GENERATES THE COLD.
WE’VE NEVER HAD ANY EFFECTIVE OR
ANY KIND OF VACCINE FOR THAT.
WE ARE SO HELPFUL ALONG WITH
YOU, THE PRESIDENT, SCIENTISTS,
EVERYBODY, THAT WE CAN GET
WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAYS THIS IS
GOING TO VANISH, WHAT DOES HE
MEAN?
IS THAT HELPFUL FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
>> IT MEANS, HARRIS, THAT WE
SHOULDN’T BE LOCKING DOWN OUR
COUNTRY, AND IT’S BECAUSE WE
HAVE REDUCED THE RISK SO MUCH
WITH THE TREATMENTS THAT ARE
COMING THROUGH THE PROCESS.
WE ARE LOOKING AT STEROIDS,
DEXAMETHASONE, THE ANTIVIRAL
REMDESIVIR YEAR, WE HAVE
REGENERON, AND ELI LILLY WITH
THE
ANTIBODY.
AND SOON THE VACCINES THAT WILL
INOCULATE NOT JUST THE VULGAR
POPULATION, BUT HEALTH CARE
WORKERS.
WE LOOK LIKE WE ARE ON TRACK FOR
THAT.
ALSO, THE GENERAL POPULATION OF
TEN AND 21.
WE WILL BE IN THE PLACE WHERE
THE RISKS WILL BE SO LOW, WILL
BE ABLE TO GET BACK TO LIFE AS
NORMAL AND GET PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK, BACK TO CHURCH, BACK TO
SCHOOL.
WE HOPE THEY CAN DO THAT NOW IN
A SAFE WAY.
REALLY, GETTING BACK TO NORMAL
IN THE COMING MONTHS.
>> Harris: I WANT TO DRILL
DOWN ON THE VACCINE, MAYBE SOME
OF THE CONVERSATIONS THE
PRESIDENT IS HAVING WITH
COMPANIES THAT YOU CAN SHARE
WITH US.
I HAVE HEARD YOU SAY, KIND OF IN
A DIFFERENT WAY, TOO, EVEN FROM
WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID.
HE HAS SAID ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS THAT A VACCINE WOULD
BE READY VERY SOON.
IN THE DEBATE LAST WEEK, CLAIMED
IT WOULD ONLY BE WEEKS.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI, IN A BBC
INTERVIEW, AGREED.
BUT HE APPEARED TO CLARIFY THOSE
COMMENTS.
LET’S WATCH.
>> WE WILL KNOW WHETHER A
VACCINE IS SAFE AND EFFECTIVE BY
THE END OF NOVEMBER, THE
BEGINNING OF DECEMBER.
THE AMOUNT OF DOSES THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE IN DECEMBER WILL NOT
CERTAINLY BE ENOUGH TO VACCINATE
EVERYBODY.
YOU’LL HAVE TO WAIT SEVERAL
MONTHS INTO 2021.
>> Harris: SO, BRIAN, I’M
CURIOUS WHAT THE CONVERSATIONS
HAVE BEEN LIKE, TEXT REALLY,
THAT YOU CAN SHARE WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE PRESIDENT, THESE COMPANIES,
DOING WHAT THEY CAN TO BUILD UP
THIS VACCINE.
>> I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION,
HARRIS, THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLARIFY.
WHAT WE ARE LOOKING AT, REALLY
WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS,
POTENTIALLY, WOULD BE SAFETY
DATA SHOWING THAT ONE OR MORE OF
THESE VACCINES IN PHASE THREE
TRIALS COULD BE SAFE.
IT WOULD BE PROBABLY ANOTHER
MONTH, DR. FAUCI STATING TOWARD
THE END OF NOVEMBER.
WE ARE PROBABLY LOOKING AT BOTH
SAFETY, EFFICACY DATA, AND THE
SAFETY DATA.
WE ARE MASS-PRODUCING THESE
VACCINES CURRENTLY, SO THAT, BY
THE END OF THE YEAR, WE’LL BE
ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOSES.
THOSE PROBABLY WILL GO TO THE
HIGH RISK POPULATION, THE SENIOR
CITIZENS, THE ELDERLY, THOSE WHO
ARE IN A MORE VULNERABLE HEALTH
STATE AS WELL AS HEALTH CARE
WORKERS.
THOSE MORE LIKELY TO BE EXPOSED
TO THE VIRUS.
THEN, OVER THE COMING MONTHS, ON
A ROLLING BASIS, WE EXPECT TO
INCREASE THE CAPACITY TO
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOSES SO
THAT, REALLY, ANYBODY WHO WANTS
A VACCINE WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE
ONE.
IT’LL BE A ROLLING PROCESS AS WE
GO THROUGH IT.
>> Harris: REAL QUICKLY -- AND
IT’S GOT TO BE QUICK -- I HEARD
YOU SAY YOU ARE ALREADY
MASS-PRODUCING SOME OF THEM.
YOU ARE MASS-PRODUCING THINGS,
AND WE ARE NOT SURE YET WHAT WE
ARE GOING TO DO WITH THEM.
YOU WOULD TOSS ALL THOSE OUT?
>> THAT’S RIGHT, HARRIS.
WE’VE DONE WITH THIS PROCESS, WE
HAVE GONE IN PARALLEL WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT, THE SAFETY, THE
DATA EVALUATION PROCESS, AND THE
MANUFACTURING PROCESS, SO THAT,
IF ONE IS DEEMED SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE, IT IS READY FOR
DISTRIBUTION REALLY IMMEDIATELY,
WITHIN 24 HOURS WE CAN GET DOSES
OUT ON THE ROAD.
IF ONE IS NOT SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE, WE WOULD DISCARD
THAT.
HARRIS, THIS IS ABOUT FIVE TIMES
FASTER THAN THE NEXT FASTEST
VACCINE HAS EVER BEEN DEVELOPED.
THIS IS A BUSINESSMAN PRESIDENT
WHO THREW EVERYTHING AT THIS
PROBLEM TO SOLVE IT AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE.
NOBODY BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD
BE THIS INNOVATIVE COME OF THIS
ENTREPRENEURIAL, AND THIS
DETERMINED TO GET THE SOLUTION
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Harris: BRIAN MORGENSTERN
TALKING ABOUT THE INNOVATION
PART OF IT.
OF COURSE, THE PART WE CAN’T
CONTROL IS THE SCIENCE.